we're going to have a look at this proof
by mathematical induction question which
in many cases we expect mathematical
induction questions to be sort of
standard it's like okay we know what the
steps are they're well defined there's a
little bit of you know often algebraic
fancy footwork you have to do
but they tend to be you know relatively
straightforward especially when you know
you start at a normal case that you're
not going up in you know multiple steps
and that kind of thing you're just
incrementing one at a time so on the
face of it this question looks quite
standard but it's actually got some
slightly unexpected teeth to it and
those will emerge as we go through the
questions so let's begin by reading it
together
use the principle of mathematical
induction to prove that if a is a real
number
such that a is greater than 0 so we're
in the positive reals then
here is the uh here's the claim right
that a to the n plus one on a to the n
is greater than or equal to a to the n
minus one plus one on a to the n minus
one for all positive integers n
greater than or equal to one all right
so let's have a go at this before i even
begin my proof i think it's always
helpful especially when everything is so
algebraic that we try and understand
what is the claim actually um you know
the thing that i'm trying to prove what
does it actually look like what does it
mean right
um often what that means is translating
the algebra into something numeric so
that we can have a sense of uh what
exactly the claim is trying to predict
because that often gives you a bit of a
path to understand uh intuitively what's
going on rather than just manipulating
symbols without knowing what the symbols
mean
so if we were to pick some like
arbitrary a and n that made the
[Music]
restrictions the domain sort of
limitations on uh and n that have been
specified here then can we get a sense
for what this looks like right
well let's suppose
if we want to try and understand this
numerically let's just suppose we take a
value like a equals three and n equals
two okay both of those fit we said that
a was in the positive reals 3 is
definitely positive and real and then n
has to be a positive integer
greater than or equal to 1. well that's
kind of implied there by being a
positive integer what would that look
like when you have a look at this
particular inequality right
well on the right hand side when we do
our substitution what are you going to
get you're going to get 3 squared which
is 9
plus 1 over 9. in fact you can see
here you're always getting that same
term on the denominator there that you
started with right so it's nine plus a
ninth so all right nine
and the ninth there there's my left hand
side and then when you imagine this for
the right hand stride right the base is
the same i'm still going to have 3 down
here in the a but the n minus 1 means
instead of squaring i just take 3 to the
1. so it's just 3. right so in this case
on the right hand side we will get 3
and the third and of course your
original term on the right left-hand
side is indeed greater than or equal to
3 and a third so what's the idea here
what's going on
well as n grows uh you're going to have
you know larger and larger numbers over
here that that sort of
whole number part the integer part will
grow and grow and grow but then your
fraction part here will get smaller and
smaller and smaller you know if i put in
n equals 3 for instance you had would
have 9 and a 9th on the right hand side
on the left hand side you would have 3
cubed which is 27 and a 27th right so
you can see the integer part is growing
the fraction part is getting smaller and
the premise is that no matter how long
you do this let's put that 27 and 1 over
27 over here
you're going to get larger and larger
results that fraction getting smaller
will never be getting so much smaller
than you have you know the integer
getting bigger in some senses you my
team say well of course that is true
right
i've i think it's of course that's true
because i've picked out an example where
it is obvious but if you start to have a
look at you know other values of a you
might say well maybe this is not quite
so um intuitive uh not quite so apparent
numerically and also you know an example
doesn't mean anything we want to prove
that this is true for all a that are
positively real and for all n that are
positive integers
and mathematical induction excels at
doing that so now we have a rough idea
of what this question is asking the
thing that we're trying to prove let's
now go about the way that a normal proof
by mathematical induction goes we know
that the three basic steps are we're
going to test the base case assume an
arbitrary case works and then prove that
if that arbitrary case works then the
next one will and that uses means that
our base case will sort of apply from n
equals 1 to 2 3 four five and so on okay
so let's begin with the test
and this is where the first curveball
arrives usually the test is a very
trivial thing but as you're going to see
here because of the algebraic nature of
this and this is why i spent so much
time thinking about this numerically
there's a curveball right from the
get-go okay now we want to think about
the base case so the base case here
comes from the positive integers n is
greater than or equal to 1. so n is
equal to 1 is the base case okay so what
i'm testing is n equals 1.
when you have a look at the left hand
side even when you put in n equals 1 you
still have a bunch of algebra here
because you have this a that is unknown
and indeed variable so i can't
substitute it for a number just to
illustrate like i did here this has to
be true for all a so therefore when i
have a look at the left hand side it's
going to be equal to if i can actually
write
a plus 1 over a
now this is our first kind of roadblock
usually when we are doing our testing
step the base case for proof by
mathematical induction we expect this to
be some kind of number now indeed a plus
1 over a is a number i just don't know
what it is because i don't know what a
is it's a variable it could be equal to
anything so i'm going to have to work on
this left hand side given that it is not
just a numerical value that i can just
put beside my other values so that's the
left hand side i'll return to this in a
second let's have a look at that right
hand side
and we have a look at our right hand
side we're going to have
a to the power of i'm testing
n equals 1 right so this is going to be
a to the power of 0 that's what 1 minus
1 will give me plus 1 over
a to the power of 0. so this is going to
give me 1 plus 1 over 1 which is also 1
so i'm getting a value of 2. so i said
before that i've got this algebra to
deal with but on the right hand side
i've got this value 2. now what i'm
hoping is that the base case is true
otherwise there's no point doing the
rest of this exercise right
how can i prove that this will always be
greater than or equal to two
it's a bunch of different tools that we
could use but for um for us knowing that
a is in the domain of the positive real
numbers right so this is not just
integers this is real numbers there's a
continuum here
when you want to prove that some
function of a real number is greater
than or equal to some other value
hopefully the place your brain is going
have a think about it i'm deliberately
not saying to give you some time to
think hopefully the place your brain is
going is actually some straightforward
differential calculus right differential
calculus allows us to find where
functions turn around if you've got a
minimum then you can say as long as
you're above that then your entire
function has to be
greater than or equal to some given
value whatever your minimum is and this
function here i think we might be able
to reason through using differential
calculus why it has to be greater than
or equal to 2 no matter what a is equal
to as long as you're in the positive
reals okay so here's what i'm going to
do
i'm going to consider
this
left hand side what i got there a plus 1
over a i'm going to consider it as its
own function um i'm going to call it
l for left-hand side and i'll write it
in index form because i'm about to
differentiate it okay
so if i've got the this new function l
and it's defined as a plus a to the
negative one it is straightforward to
differentiate this and then i just need
to see if i can find some kind of
minimum that will imply
that it's going to be greater than or
equal to this particular value that i'm
searching for okay so in order to do
that i need to differentiate the first
time for starters so that gives me dl on
da rather than the dy on dx that we're
used to
the a is just going to differentiate
down to 1 so that's great
and then that a to the negative 1 is
going to differentiate down into
multiply by the power and then
reduce that by one okay so
this thing here i need to think about
well
does it have a minimum right
or rather does this imply that there's
going to be a minimum here and the
answer is yeah it does because you can
see this is clearly going to have some
solutions that i can determine the
nature of
and i'm hoping that they're going to
give me a minimum so let's have a think
about this right
stationary points or i should say
turning points because that's the actual
thing i'm searching for turning points
may exist
may exist because you may get stationary
points and really what i'm interested in
is turning points may exist when this
derivative is equal to zero dl on da is
equal to zero in other words i've got
one minus i put it into index form so
that i could differentiate but i've done
that now for now anyway so i'm going to
put it back into a form that makes it
easier to deal with in terms of solving
this equation 1 over a squared equals 0
and when i'm going to solve this you can
clearly see that 1 over a squared that's
got to be equal to 1. so a squared
itself has got to be equal to 1. so
there's going to be 2 potential values
here but i already have a domain
restriction on a
it tells me that
a is a positive real number so i can
disregard that negative solution so a
equals 1
only
now what i am hoping for because what
i'm trying to prove what i expect to be
true is that this function has in the
given domain for the positive reals it
has a minimum and that minimum is either
2 or above 2 right because then the
left-hand side will indeed be greater
than or equal to the right-hand side for
all values of a so in order to prove
that well i have i found a turning point
or a stationary point i should say and i
want to prove that it is a particular
kind of turning point namely a minimum
right now given the kind of function
that we've got here i think it is very
straightforward to differentiate a
second time and then just use the um
concavity to be able to prove that this
is hopefully going to be a minimum so
let's have a go
second derivative i can say
d squared l on d a squared is going to
be equal to
that one differentiates away because
it's a constant and then i'm going to
get negative 2 times that negative so
that's just going to be 2 and then i'm
going to reduce the power by 1.
so
when i put in a equals 1
i can say when a equals 1
that second derivative is going to be
equal to
2 times or 2 divided by 1 cubed which is
indeed 2 so that is
concave up
and that
is a minimum
so this is i mean it was a proof
question so i expected this was the case
but i had to show it right
this shows me that i'm going to have a
minimum so it's going to be facing up so
that's great but i have to know it's a
minimum that is above
or equal to this value right because if
you've got a minimum it goes below
that's no good you're not going to be
greater than or equal to this value at
any given spot so therefore i can say
the minimum value occurs at a equals 1.
when
a equals 1
now i've got a specific value of a to
actually test out in my left hand side l
is going to be equal to 1 plus 1 over 1.
right that's how i defined there it is
that's what l is equal to and thankfully
that is equal to exactly 2. so my
minimum is 2 and what i wanted to prove
was i.e
the left-hand side is greater than or
equal to the specific value for the
right-hand side that i found which was
also 2. so
um that was just the base case that was
your first curveball we're not out of
the woods yet but have a look at that
usually your base case is a little bit
more straightforward to work out but
we have succeeded we've tested for n
equals 1 which is the lowest value it
can take on the left-hand side is indeed
greater than the right-hand side so
thumbs up we can proceed